hello everyone and welcome to another
game from the extra con open we said
that we were gonna check up on how
Prabhu is doing as he was the sole
leader after seven rounds of the the
extra can open here is a game from the
penultimate round he faces morally
Karthikeyan not so long ago we've shown
a game that he played a really a
brilliant Queen sacrifice in the style
of Rashid Nash Medina
if you haven't seen it do check it out
it's truly amazing it will be the first
thing you see in the description below
just click on it and you know enjoy some
nice nice Queen sacrificing but this
game like I said penultimate round of of
the extra can open program Anand up with
the white pieces let's check out the
game as it is a very nice game prog wins
with Knight to f3 we have the ready
Knight to f6 G 3G sex and birth of the
g2 we have Bishop to g7 castles castles
and now d4 so everything you know pretty
standard it's interesting to mention I
think Perignon and ax is the 27th seed
in this tournament so a lot of players
are high rated in him even more ly
Kartik in here is over 2600 whereas
Prabhu is 25 40 something I just thought
you might be interested in that and I
know a lot of you asked me to return the
ratings but there is a very specific
reason why I don't show the ratings
below players names I only did it a few
times
sometimes you're doing engine games and
of course during the World Chess
Championship and magic between and
Kahlan and Cara wanna but maybe in the
future I will consider it somewhere with
v6 rook to e1 and now c5 just challenged
in the center D characters D captures
and now the main line here is just the
trade Queens here but probably undergoes
four c3 it's a very rare line it has
only been played once before this game
in 1997 in Zagreb opened in Croatia
sergeant Martin Clunes played it against
your super Munich and the game ended in
a draw but that game continued with Bush
up to five but here we have Queen to b6
Kartikeya now chooses a different line
and it is as a move 8 that we have a
completely new game so now the Queen is
developed you want to bring this rock
over to d8 as white women still is still
on d1
so Quinta a four by pregnant Wanda we
have nice to see six and now night the a
three going for c4 we have a six Knight
to c4 attacking blacks Queen and Queen
to b5 now here pregnant on the trait
with clean captures pawn captures
attacking the knight and the night the
b6 attacking the rook and the bishop
rook to a6 forcing the knight to move
Knight captures and see it rook captures
on see it and now just a three so now
when you look at this position black's
pawn structure is a bit messed up he has
doubled be pawns and pregnant and that
still has the bishop repair so it's not
much to go on but it is something on the
other hand black has a semi-open a file
for the rook if he can do something with
that well he definitely should so before
of course you want to open up and get
rid of your doubled pawn on the Queen
side you cannot capture here as a white
rook still aren't connected so C capture
some before we have see capture some
before and now rook the b1 so now if
black goes for this trade after trading
at the white rook will already be
targeting b7 we have night Stewie for by
black and pound Knight to g5 offering a
trade of knights and Knight to d6 not
allowing it if you trade then white gets
to develop the bishop for free so knight
back to b6 and now a capture some before
and here morally doesn't recapture right
away there's time to recapture doubled
pawns he first wants to improve his
position first rook to b6 now he will be
able to choose if he wants to maybe
capture with the night or with the rook
with b3 and doesn't one this pawn to
remain a target here also maybe creates
room on b2 for his dark square Bishop
with Bishop to c3 now attacking the rook
and now with a triple attack against the
b4 pawn rook to d1 and now Knight the d4
so still taking it easy there's always
time to recapture here but he wants to
capture on e2 with check so King to f1
programming on the defense with the
Queen and now rook to e8 still waiting
to recapture the b-pawn we have worked
to be three attacking the bishop here
and now rook to a-1 forcing a trade
route captures Bishop characters and he
Bishop to d2 so here program analyst
says now you cannot capture on before
but Karthikeyan goes night to c2 so now
the before pawn is attacked once again
so all in all he wants to equalize and
then you know see see what what can be
done in this position with Knight e4 now
offering a trade and here we have Bishop
back to e5 it's interesting if you
capture for example Knight capture son
before attacking the rook white will go
Bishop e3 attack this rope and now after
Knight captures rook Bishop captures
here Knight c8 attacks the bishop bishop
goes back to e3 and 95 you have this
position but the problem is that white
still has the bishop pair and the bishop
pair as you know is always very deadly
it will be somewhat difficult to hang on
to this point and then white will use
the bishop pair at the escort hit his
probably soon to be pass pawn up the
board so this is one way to do it
morely doesn't doesn't like his chances
there so he goes Bishop to e5 just
bringing another defender to the night
here and what can white do here I feel
free to pause the video here and try to
find the best idea for pregnant in this
position well I give you a couple of
seconds for those of you who were able
to do it congratulations you are an
excellent finder of winning moves with
the rook and for those who just want to
enjoy the show
the move is rook to d5 it's a pretty
concrete idea you're attacking the
bishop the bishop now has to move so
where do you move it one way is to
defend it with f6 the problem with f6 is
9595 now threatens Knight a for to win
the rook and you can't really do all
that much here for example if you know
if you capture Knight capture Sun before
just Knights to a4 and now you will not
be able to move the rook as you have to
keep an eye on the knight on d4 so it's
a very tricky idea to go for for this f6
idea and on the other hand if you move
the bishop back well the problem is you
just brought the bishop from there so
for example if you play Bishop to b2
this was played in the game but now
pregnant under just wins a pawn Knight
captures on d6 ok if you capture with
the rook then it's all over row
character C captures and Bishop
character sin b7
now you will easily use the bishop pair
and already the bishop is guarding the
before points when I were just gonna
move the bishop and push your past on to
victory
so of course Karthikeyan did not go for
this he played pawn captures on d6 and
now Bishop the f4 pregnant under now
goes for the d6 pawn also a possibility
was b5 just force that rook to remain
there
now the rook cannot move a six and of
course e6 are covered Bishop to a5 is
the threat you're just you know planning
to win the rook and now after Knight d4
only way to play this Bishop to a5
attacking the rook and now rook
characters on b5 it's not a problem
rook captures Knight captures and again
Bishop captures on b7 you're gonna move
your Bishop start pushing your phone and
it's gonna be a well it's gonna be a
swift victory so here after eight
characters and v6 program Honda did not
go for b5 he played Bishop to f4
just a different line and now Bishop to
e5 with bunch of characters pawn
captures rook captures Knight captures
and before and now although it's you
know still seems like a playable
position a pregnant man that has a rook
to e7 and now there's no way of
defending the b7 pawn with Knight to c6
attacking the rook and now rook d7 first
here trying to get black the capture on
before if rook captures before then you
get Bishop d5 where you will just grab a
lot of material so King to f8 not
allowing the D F pawn to be pinned and
also preparing King - eh to push away
the rook but now rush up to d5 attacking
the pawn here and the Knights the e7
blocking the rook we've pushed back to C
for now the b3 pawn nicely protected not
a lot for black to do here we have King
to e8 attacking the rook and now rook
the c7 with f6 and now the King can move
as the f7 pawn will not be a target with
rook the c5 not allowing the King to
attack the roof with tempo
King to d7 and now rook to a5 now with
Knight to c6 attacking the rook rook to
b5 offering a roof trade and King to c7
and now rook the c5 again with King to
d6 route d5 check King
the east 7 and now finally f4 with night
two before attacking program Amanda's
rook here Luke the c5 and now tonight
back to c6 or Karthikeyan really forcing
pregnant andhe to figure out how to go
about this he does have an extra point
but can can he push for a win with his
extra point against the 2600 plus Grand
Master program Honda says yes he can he
pushes efore with rook to be 4 and now
finally what you always want to do in an
end game you start bringing your King
into the game King F two knights to d4
now with a double attack against the b3
pawn rook the c7 check although if you
don't move the knight it's hard to find
any activity you have to allow this rook
to infiltrate otherwise you're just
gonna allow King to e3 and then no more
night jumps are possible so here Carter
King decides to activate 94 we have rook
c7 check King to d6 and now rook
captures on h7 knife capture son b3
grabs at pawn Bishop captures rook
captures not allowing the King to reach
the third rank but it's not a problem
rook h6 now just gonna gobble up these
pawns there's no way to defend them with
b5 Karthikeyan starts pushing this pass
pawn on the Queen side and I'll just the
rook captures on g6 king c7 we have rook
captures on f6 and now before and now
okay it's a somewhat an advanced past
pawn but pregnant under has four
connected passed pawns which is well
which is pretty much winning even if you
give up this rook somehow for this pawn
four points against the rook
there's just no no way around it program
that starts pushing to his own passport
with E 5 Ruby to check now King f3 we
have Ruby 3 check King g4 no more checks
now rook d3 making room for the past
pawn but now rook to a 6
we have rook to e3 trying to get this
trade in of course this would be great
for black as so pregnant under declined
said we have looked at these six and now
b3 rogue d1 preparing to block with rook
to be 1 we have b2 and now rook to be 1
and here it was in this position on more
58 that morally Karthikeyan resigned the
game as there is nothing more
to be done here you have to defend your
passport and then well wife will just
start bringing stinking a5 you can bring
your king to f7 just pull this point to
victory at some point black will have to
prevent this then white will capture
this pawn and then you're just winning
with all those nice pass points on the
under King side so that's pretty much
the game I do hope you enjoyed it here I
did prepare the standings which is just
insane and also well before I actually
show you the standings I want to show
you something else but it didn't prepare
to just give me a second I mean I did
prepare it I just didn't prepare to show
it to you which will take me maybe three
more seconds yeah it's right over here
I think nope not there sorry about that
no idea why it's it's taking me so long
to find it all right almost there I
think this is it
yep this is it there we go sorry about
that there you have it
these are pregnant honest opponents in
the extra [ __ ] 2019 so let's just check
it out so as you can see he finished the
tournament with eight and a half out of
ten after four wins
he starts facing yeah well he had two
low-rated opponents then to freedom
masters and then he faced six
grandmasters in a row and this is
amazing out of out of fighting six
grandmasters all six higher rated than
himself and not one of them rated below
2600 he achieved three wins and three
draws and you know those are very strong
grandmasters on tone core above really
just a beast daniel booko Toro we've
seen this game and moolah Karthikeyan
also a very strong grandmaster and in
the final round after well fighting all
those grandmasters he drew against
Samuel 7 the the Grandmaster his sister
defeated in round three so the advice
charlie also somewhat helped in in
Prague winning first place but you know
who knows it you know the probably
doesn't even matter about you know
if if she didn't beat him then he would
have faced someone else and everything
would have a you know been differently
so yeah that's pretty much it that's
what I wanted to show you and here a
short table of the standings there you
have it
Prabhu first with eight and a half with
so lead ahead of all the other players
who are tied with eight points are the
entire league Gabrielle sarkeesian
afghani Poston is Samuel Sabean and
Allen Zig Rasmussen so really an
impressive showing you can see the
progress rating is twenty five hundred
and forty and he finished with twenty
seven hundred and forty one rating
performance so he won some thirty rating
points maybe a little below that but
really insane when you can you know play
against six grandmasters in a row and
win rating who are all higher rated than
yourself when when any rating is is a
lot winning thirty rating points when
you're Grandmaster is just insane so big
congratulations to Prague nonde you know
going after that 2600 rating barrier I'm
pretty sure he's gonna get there very
soon and then you know it's off to the
2700 as as that happens so once again I
do hope you enjoy the story about taking
me so long to locate the the table no
you know I really have to start naming
my folders properly but yeah thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day of course you
can check in two of them my previous
videos here you know have an excellent
rest of your Sunday